got a game that I want to play with you
it's called the cheat code I'm gonna
show you four offensive lineups and you
can tell me which one is breaking the
most scoring records offense number one
is Lamar Jackson Mike Evans Travis
Kelsey Derrick Henry and David bakhtiari
it's gonna be too hard to choose
everybody's gonna be great here's office
number two we got Josh Allen Mike Evans
Justin Jefferson Trent Williams and Lane
Johnson offense number two is gonna pass
the [ __ ] out the ball I'll tell you that
right now offense two Josh likes to
sling The Rock a lot of targets and this
is offense number three Patrick Mahomes
Mike Evans AJ Brown Quinn Nelson and
sequan Barkley me and AJ were really
physical receivers hacking can make
plays out of the pocket in the pocket he
can throw it off his back foot 70 yards
yeah that's a that's a scary offense
right there offense number four we got
Kirk Cousins Mike Evans Tyreek Hill
George Kittle and Nick Chung sheesh you
like that shout out Kirk man he's always
had swag he's a really smart quarterback
good ball placement he's very underrated
cheetah man fastest player I've ever
seen with my own two eyes me seeing it
from a pass rush point of view the type
of headaches that it would give on
everybody I gotta go with offense number
two Josh Allen of course Trent Williams
and Lane Johnson on the same team oh my
God Mike Evans and Justin Jefferson who
then you got Josh Allen like what I mean
what people would lose sleep over this
offense I'm gonna go offense number
three like I'm a huge private homes fan
AJ Brown is doing his thing Quinn Nelson
is a beast and saquan's a beast and he
needs to get paid so I go to